yeah I'm so excited to see you you're
such an inspiration to so many people
and you look beautiful today thank you
so do you I feel like we've sort of bad
right oh yeah we got the black memo oh
you look amazing
I love black it selects everything in it
makes you look incredible that's what we
we're proud and you were here for a very
important reason because you're on tour
with Jonas Brothers yes must be so
exciting who do you like to hang out
with Sophie Priyanka or Danielle I well
I've met Danielle he's total sweetheart
amazing body so fit mm-hmm like there
wasn't muscles on like there was muscles
on her muscles on her legs
I met Sophie and I absolutely loved Game
of Thrones so every time I walked by
their dressing room and like I see her
and Joe and they're like so cute
together I like like kind of the third
wheel yeah like I'll walk in and just
like start saying something and I heard
that Priyanka actually passed by the
dressing room the other day and called
out my name but I wasn't there so she I
still have yet to meet Priyanka and I
don't know how I'm probably gonna be
fangirling but I usually hang out the
wives I'm most excited to meet the wives
yeah I love the brothers they're like my
brothers yeah but you know it's all of
the wires sorry and they're pretty
incredible wives too so yes they've all
been I mean from Sophie and Danielle so
sweet
like no diva no demoness like just chill
girls just chilled girls and talking
about chill it's not really chill for
you to be on stage because you are
performing some of the best songs that
are out there right now meant to be is
massive yeah it must be exciting for you
to be up there when fans go crazy when
you're about to sing that song do you
get tired of singing it ever um you know
like when you're performing it in front
of 15,000 Jonas Brothers fans it's it
doesn't and they sing all the words it
doesn't get tiring I think that it's
just it's for me such an incredible
opportunity to be performing in front of
their crowd because they're most a lot
of them are my age and you know you know
in their 20s and I just feel like every
time I perform it I can never get sick
of it yeah never you know and it's
actually cool to watch people's faces be
like yeah that's the girl you know
because a lot of times I I write songs
and I'm part of songs I feel don't
what my face what I live like and that's
really cool when they put two and two
together and that song got a Grammy
nomination yeah so we didn't win I got
it it's okay you got the nomination
which is so yeah which was amazing yeah
cuz then now they'll forever say
two-time Grammy nominated and every time
I hear that I'm like it's pretty amazing
it feels weird yeah but that night was
special
you killed it on the red carpet and you
were a voice and you use your platform
and yeah I want to say thank you too
yeah because I dealt with some of the
trolls online and really I did I got
body shame - you did and it hurts oh you
know what you got to you got to ignore
the body shaming I just feel like now
we're in such a different you know worse
in such a different what's the word
landscape yeah especially for women it
doesn't matter what your size is it
doesn't matter matter what your age is
you just really got a I just feel like
we're all beautiful mind of that like I
I get insecure sometimes I think I'm
human like every I'm inai I know I'm
human like everyone else it gets tough
because in the end the day I am in the
public eye and if you complain about it
then it's look you know it just doesn't
seem right it sounds like why am I here
and it's a blessing for me to be doing
what I love and when I speak out about
you know whether it's age or sizing it's
it's it's not that I've been the first
to do it I'm just not scared you're not
like I'm just gonna speak out about it
it's been happening for years and years
and you would be surprised about the
amount of artists and females that have
been hitting me up but like you know or
like Taylor you know commenting on my
pictures Swift and yeah and and Demi
Lovato and but like you know they've
been doing it out and open but there's
people been people texting me like even
songwriters and writers and artists and
in executives who have been going
through a lot of stuff all their lives
and I'm just speaking out yeah what does
it mean for you to know though women are
supporting women especially in the
industry right now you just said Taylor
Swift yeah and I think you tweet a dead
dead dead or something yeah I'm gonna
definitely you know I know she's sorry I
know she's swearing a Grammy party so my
goal is to go to the Grammy party and
get
picture with Taylor because I think
especially everything she's been going
through I feel like she's a very strong
woman and and the fact that she's able
to speak out now and and and really just
stand for what she believes in is very
empowering to me and I think that now
we're at a time where we are able to
speak up speak out and I think not only
just kind of I think we should take this
platform and use make a positive out of
it you know instead of you know we don't
want it to be this thing where it's like
women oh here comes another woman
speaking out here we go I think we need
to take it to the next level and really
say like we're helping each other and
we're gonna we're gonna push ourselves
to the next level and make room for
other females or women coming into
whatever industry we're in yeah is it
just ridiculous people react the way
they do I mean I mean listen like you
know you told me you're Indian like I
come from a background where it's it's
it's hard you know throughout the world
we don't see it because we're here in
America but throughout the world there
are many women and young girls who are
being told they can't dress a certain
way that they can't speak at the dinner
table that they have to get married to a
certain age or get married off and
sometimes when you speak out you really
are giving you know you give these women
and girls a chance to or like feel like
empowered to say something and to break
through you know naming and to really
become who they could be
you know they mean oh thank you so much
- don't you feel like don't you feel
like don't you feel like there's under
other Indian girls who look up to you
and they say wow like this could be me
one day
you know it's like I'm with my culture -
it's like you usually get married to
some get married off to somebody else of
the same culture and it's like I was
like no I'm not doing that
and gonna go to California and make
music and in waking music maybe one day
you will be collaborating with Taylor
Swift is that something you would love
to do put 30 Katie I think she is one
bad she sorry I love love no pun
intended
no no but you heard it it's great yeah
it's incredible I mean it anything that
she does is amazing and I love the fact
that she's a songwriter and writes her
own records and that's something that I
just really look up to oh I can't
for that collaboration to happen one day
hopefully and this is a big year for you
you're turning 30 on August 30th how
nice is that that's champagne you're
right I think it is they say it's the
able they say well first of all I heard
that it's a what does it call the golden
years all the way back because here's
something you get something because I'm
30 on August 30 and then I'm performing
at Madison Square Garden where it is a
New York City which is where I'm from
and you know that all my family is gonna
be there and I'm putting a song out that
day which is you know a song about
saying that you could be sexy at any age
and that I'm no longer gonna be in my
20s and then I'm turning 30 because I
feel like throughout my career I've
always felt a little embarrassed about
my age like I was always told like you
can't tell people your real age like you
don't like lie you don't I mean like
nobody will know and I always feel like
that was a little weird because I'm like
what if you lie about your age and then
somebody finds out like that's not a
cool look you know it's like that
everything you work for is now hidden by
you lying about your age so I never lied
about my age and I feel like everybody's
always like let's stay young forever
which is amazing but I think that's
something saying young forever is
something in your spirit in your soul
and I think that there definitely is
don't kill me and how can it kill for
this or no but I feel like when guys get
older they get sexier and I feel like
when females get older like we turn into
like hags or something and that our eggs
are drying up and we have to have kids
so I think for me this song is about
being like there's no I mean let there's
no age about there's no age you can't be
sexy obviously unless you're like under
18 but but like you know above you know
it's like when you're like an adult you
can you I mean I think older you get the
more wiser you guys at 40 I just turned
40 this year and I need this right wrist
I feel I feel damn word yeah my dad was
sick of me already know but like that
you know your back do you feel more sexy
you feel more confident because you you
know empowerment because I think at a
certain time right like you feel like
you don't really have anything to you
really don't feel like you have to
improve at least for anybody's approvals
anymore I feel like all my life I feel
like
I don't know if I should I don't know if
this what if I don't look at with this
and it's like at a certain point you're
like this is what I feel good in this is
what I want to do this is who I am and
if you don't like it that's okay because
you can't please any everyone yeah you
really can't and that's the whole thing